[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone
delighted to have you with us those here
at MIT and those at a distance I'm my
name is Tom Magnanti I'm one of the
co-directors of the system design and
management program and it's my pleasure
to welcome you to our first
distinguished lecture series in complex
systems we are very fortunate to have
with us today and I over this semester
professor Thomas Hughes distinguished
professor and I think it's probably
appropriate to say Dean of the history
of Technology in the United States and
maybe in the world professor Hughes is
well known for his insightful look at
technology particularly look at
large-scale projects and of developing a
framework for looking at these projects
and for providing insight for all of us
at technical institutions such as MIT
and elsewhere we're just delighted to
have Professor use with us on this
occasion he's going to give two public
addresses the first adjustable today and
the second address will be on October
30th and maybe also be meeting with the
system design and management students in
a more intimate setting I just like to
for those familiar with the system
design a management program it's an
educational program at MIT whose intent
is to educate future technical leaders
in architecting engineering and
designing complex systems and complex
products the intellectual content of
this program revolves around complexity
complex systems and complex products
there clearly are many ways to look at
complexity there's various modeling
approaches to looking in it there's
engineering ways of looking at it but
certainly among those viable ways of
looking at technology is a historical
perspective of trying to understand
lessons from history
what we've learned from the evolution of
our understanding of complex systems our
understanding of technology and
professor you as that thinks brings
brings a rather unique perspective on
that in terms of his understanding a
particular of large-scale projects he
has written many books and many articles
his most recent book is rescuing
Prometheus it's a very notable we hope
will improve it like for the control and
see if we can improve it
his most recent book rescuing Prometheus
has gotten a great deal of attention it
was I think a month or month and a half
ago was reviewed in The New York Times
two weeks ago he was on National Public
Radio to talk about this book and I've
got quite a rousing response as I
understand from my conversation with him
a few minutes ago he is also very much
intertwined with the system does not
always let me try another microphone
then he wants this I hope this is a
little bit better
he's intimately involved I spent only
involved with the systems design a
management program I think about six
years ago or so now we had a committee
at MIT that was convened by our previous
dean of engineering Provost Joel Moses
and Dan Roos our associate dean for
engineering systems that was looking at
large-scale systems and we brought
together at that time engineers
management people from MIT
anthropologists historians to try to get
our arms around this whole issue of
large scale systems and I think that was
a previous equation application which
professor used was visiting MIT and he
joined us in those deliberations and so
I think it's fair to say that he's had a
touch from the beginning and the overall
direction and orientation of this
program system design and management
I think those of us involved with the
program couldn't think of anyone better
to inaugurate this lecture series
distinguished lecture series and complex
systems and then professor Hughes who
will tell us a little bit about I think
some of the elements of his book and
some of the projects that he's been
involved with and provide us with his
own unique perspective on these issues
professor use thank you Tom she's all
right coming through all right for I'm
very generous introduction I'm very
happy to be here talking to the people
about whom I write that his engineers
historians do not have this opportunity
very often I'm very fortunate to have it
this afternoon and on other occasions
Tom mentioned this National Public Radio
he said I got a good response I'm not
sure was a good response I got an
interesting response I'll tell you about
it very briefly before I go into my
prepared remarks this this the program
is called the public issue of public
concerns public issue comes on every day
in the week and after the guests
described is interviewed about a book or
some other activity then the audience
I'm saying radio Lyon has an opportunity
to call in and ask questions I was
getting a rather expected what I
expected by way of questions until
somebody from Pennsylvania named Mike I
believe I called in and he said a
professor I don't want you to think that
I'm a crock but he said when I was young
aliens abducted me this is over National
Public Radio aliens abducted me I spent
time with them and I know in your book
you write about intercontinental
ballistic missiles and computer networks
and I happen to know from being with the
aliens that all of this is reversed
alien engineering well he said do you
did you find any evidence to support
this so the person who was interviewing
me was rolling her eyes and all I could
think of saying was I've only been able
to interview Earthlings and I said but
you have these contacts and if you can
renew them and do some serious
interviewing then turn these over to
historians we can use this to revise an
interpretation so I'm at this this is
true I mean if he comes through those
interviews we will revise our
interpretations so he seemed quite
satisfied today my subject is systems
does creating systems creating large
complex systems as Tom said first a word
about the historical approach which you
will share with me today I think what
the historian can do can help engineers
in several ways
one way is to put in engineers present
work into some perspective I hope today
the when I described several very the
creation of several very large systems
that you will be those of you who are
into system design and management will
be drawing analogies on your own with
what I'm describing historical cases
with what you experience in your work
today in yesterday and tomorrow and
incidentally if you find that my
description of these two systems the
Edison Electric Light and Power System
in the opponet system their creation I
should stress don't hesitate to
interrupt me and point out where you
think I might have gone astray in my
interpretations of the creation of these
systems
be giving as Tom said several lectures
so I have a few opening definitions for
these definitions I wish to use
initially definitions of closed systems
and open systems now I noticed I've read
the biographical sketches of a number of
those of you who are now here in the
open systems program I'm sorry in the
systems development managing systems
design management program and I know
some of you are in product design and
others of you are in what I am talking
about today managing projects but I I
assume that those of you in product
design often the activity you are
engaged in is called a project and so I
believe what I will say today even
though it's about it's not about product
say in the automobile industry or
products and the photographic industry
it is about products now here is a
product I could I call this say a closed
system it could be called a technical
system in a moment when I give you a
visual of an open system you will see
the distinction now this Syst this
diagram is from a technical journal
around 1892 I believe some in that
period it's an electric light and power
systems obviously what I think you might
note here is that as early as 1890 to
engineers and managers were quite
capable of combining heterogeneous
components into a general system you
will notice that some of the appliances
here run on very high voltage like the
industrial motors some on low-voltage
like the electric light in the electric
electric lights some have one frequency
other appliances or components have
another frequency but by 1895 or there
my engineers had developed what I think
you might call gateway devices
transformers motor generator sets and so
forth that allowed heterogeneous
components to be put on a single system
so it is a closed system in that it's a
technical system but it is complex and
now would like to show an open system
now what I hope I can contribute to your
program and and through other talks that
I shall give at MIT is opening your
minds if they're not already open to the
importance of open systems open systems
as you see from the diagram include
organizational components along with
technical components and a number of
system builders engineers and managers
over history over a long period of time
in Germany and in the United States and
elsewhere in the world these some of
these people have been quite good in
designing open systems and creating open
systems now I'm my impression is that in
most engineering schools I'm not sure
about MIT I'm fairly sure though the
emphasis is not put upon open systems
they considered soft the emphasis upon
the closed technical systems but from my
interviewing of a number of engineers in
the large complex systems well I find
that a number of you you perhaps but
certainly you the compatriots your
compatriots your peers whom I have
interviewed are in fact designing
developing open systems and as a matter
of fact they tell me they enjoy it very
much
they are messy and some people consider
the work soft it's not eloquent Allen
eloquent and elegant and its
quantitative is closed systems but it is
a these designing these is a challenge
which young engineers enjoy I'm thinking
especially of in
Janee as I enjoyed and so on yes I
enjoyed I interviewed on the central
artery and tunnel project and I would
ask them how do you feel about this
bringing into the the design of the
system environmental controls taking
into account and neighborhood politics
actually rewriting the system because of
community concerns and generally they
said it makes the design project much
more interesting
but they added several of the people I
interviewed that some of the some of the
older persons did not find this
congenial and would not continue in the
project now let's take a look at this
for just a moment what I wish I had up
here in this diagram was a consulting
engineering firm and also a utility a
utility organization should certainly be
there and if I'd had those two and I'd
put those two into my child then I could
say this is very much like the system
that the head of German General Electric
which was called algum on electricity
gesellschaft the open system that algum
on electricity gesellschaft
raj created in germany around 1910 it
was a system presided over by a man
named Walter Rathenau who was an open
system building very good at it
now let me just spend a moment on this
the point here is let's look at the bank
a main like rotten now when he created
the system and then later used it and he
was trained as a physicist and an
engineer he was the head of German
General Electric which was not related
to American General Electric Rodney said
Rodney I wanted some control over the
bank he also wanted some control of the
consulting engineering company and let's
take the bank for example if his
consulting engineering and construction
company which he owned stock Ian or his
company owned stock
in Ajo in stock e'en if construction
activity had fallen off then if he had
influence over the bank he would he
would urge the bank to lower its
interest rates and so that those
considering construction projects would
be more enticed by the money market and
so that was interaction and rotten-ass
sought between a bank and a construction
firm in the field and also in this
diagram they should be a manufacturing
company and rata now through sitting on
a number of boards of directors had
influence and manufacturing companies
and in utilities and he brought about a
sim symbiosis between what the utilities
were needing by way of equipment and
what the electrical manufacturers were
producing or would produce so what we
have here functional interrelationships
and some persons have the vision in in
as we will see in a moment in our world
today to to put together these various
components into into an interacting
system one thing driving these people
who do this and to me they're
fascinating people and I think in with
all due respects and mr. gates is one of
these people these people want control
and they want control not for nefarious
reasons but they want control in order
to get the system to function in an
optimal way so there's a DRI of control
now if I could have the next visual this
is from the New Yorker magazine and
several several months ago and here we
have media companies and you know one of
the media companies is is Microsoft and
I think most of you are well aware of
this but maybe I should remind you of it
that Microsoft is creating these
functional interrelationships and
perhaps one of the driving instincts of
Bill Gates
is to create these kinds of interactions
to have this type of control
if you run down Microsoft just Microsoft
either through direct ownership or
through stock ownership or some other
mode of influence as you will see is in
decay both TV and film production
internet technology internet content and
so forth and you see these are all media
in engagements media activities and you
can understand if he has the mode of
distribution say the Internet it's an
instinct to get the control of the
content that goes over the over the
distribution over the media over the
modes of distribution but if we went
back to the other diagram German General
Electric in 1910 you had the same
phenomena you had the distribution
system that was also the generation of
content that is electrons and then
setter etcetera etc so these are open
systems I have another very complex
diagram here if we can show the next one
lean this allsorts from The New Yorker
and the question being asked the person
writing the essay in doing the diagram
is all these media concerns which I
showed you a moment ago are they
competing are they are they
collaborating and this diagram shows
companies that are owned our companies
in which control is influenced that
connect the spiders the bugs across the
the lines drawn between them and you
could study that and you'll see a number
of companies jointly owned cetera etc
etc so this is a very complex open
system and again the reason it's an open
system is because organizations are part
the system I repeat and their technical
components in the system now this is
called that was called a web of
collaboration from now word about
projects I would argue and perhaps some
of my friends here from the Sloan School
would not accept my argument have some
in the audience will not accept the
audience the argument but it seems to me
from reading the history of engineering
management my concern is with the
management that has a core engineering
core and often the people I interview
and the companies are right about are
managed by persons with engineering
backgrounds so that's the type of
management I'm speaking of now the it
seems to me looking back over a hundred
years that that projects are becoming
increasingly the activity in which
engineers are involved projects and as I
said projects can certainly include
product development let me spend a few
more moments on this if one were an
engineer imagine yourself an engineer in
1920 and you'd accepted a job this is my
hypothesis and happy to have it
critiqued and you accepted a job at the
Ford Motor Company and went to Detroit
in 19 say nineteen twenty five still
making the Model T I think you would
expect as an engineer that you would be
asked to improve the functioning of the
assembly lines at River Rouge in Holland
Park you would also be engaged in some
improvement in the Model Model T but you
would expect these changes to be
cumulative
as an engineer I don't think you would
expect to be involved in projects that
would bring about radical changes in the
assembly line or in the product and also
you would not expect a need to go back
to MIT or some other institution in
order to keep abreast of the discipline
in which you were working that's what I
believe in 1925 engineer would feel
going to work he or she at the Ford
Motor Company mostly he's then of course
but today one funds that they are you
may become involved in a project in the
project might bring about a radical
transformation in product software a
hardware or radical transformation in
the way the production line is
functioning and these projects remind me
in many ways of the theater a friend of
mine who is director and a producer when
I told her about these projects and
engineers are so often involved and she
said oh what you're telling me about its
open open casting and I asked her to
elaborate up on that she's sorry we're
doing a play we're not a repertory
company we're doing a play we announced
open casting and I know that companies
like and the Sonata let's do this an
announcement is made such and such a
project will be put into place the
project might engage you for two or
three months or maybe even a year or
more and then after you come join this
project and then when the project
fulfills its goal then we will disperse
and you may become involved in another
project in the case of the theater open
casting you make an announcement we are
we are we're doing the Iceman Cometh
people from all over the Manhattan area
will come and try out for parts you put
these people together for a while they
hearse for months they put on a
production and after the run is complete
they disperse incidentally that this
open casting when you announce that you
are going to do a play that's a cattle
call incidentally now they also
repertory companies that do not have
cattle calls and open casting but they
have the same people as you know doing
different projects with the same people
and you'll find both of these forms in
the in the industrial world in the
military world and in the university
where today virtual projects as you know
they're sometimes called and I will
describe in a matter of a few minutes
the a project one of the classic
projects classic projects of history I
think most of you have heard of it
perhaps some of you have read about it I
note that people in the systems design
and management some of you are
interested in history well this is one
of the great historical episodes and
that is the creation by Thomas Edison
and his group during the period from
about 1878 to 1882 of an electric
lighting power system now what I hope I
will be able to do in briefly describing
this project is give you what I consider
to be the essence of project the project
essence and the projects you may be
involved in different detail of course
and projects done throughout history
differ in many ways but I'm hoping to
capture the essence of a project by
going through this historical episode
first program management
I'm contrasting program management and
project management I'm drawing upon some
NASA policies in this regard and also in
the past at least and many of the things
I say come from the pain
NASA defined program management
different blade from project management
now first program management in the case
of Electric Light and Power System
program management people involved in
this are concerned about funding and are
concerned about politics and then
sometimes they must become involved in
organizational creation as well and in
the case of this particular project an
organization had been formed and as I go
through this perhaps you'll be impressed
as I am every time I involve myself with
the history of this project had
contemporary this Edison story is in its
in its details I I perhaps you would
agree with me perhaps not but a company
was formed 1870 called the Edison
Electric Light Company
now the Edison Electric Light Company
was formed by the program manager types
one of these was a man named groves no
Larry who was a very prominent New York
City lawyer an incident is not unusual
to find people from law and other
disciplines involved with engineers in
these open system creations
now Grosvenor Larry was the lawyer for
the for the Western Union Telegraph
Company so he was working in the world
of technology Larry said I think we
should create an electric light system
I'll explain why he chose that problem
in a moment he said this to Edison he
said first we must create this company
and this company will be an investment
in patent holding company what's new
it will fund Edison's activities it will
take over his patents it will get a
return on the investment this is venture
capital in 1878 and the company was
formed another thing Larry did and this
is another requirement of open systems
as some of you here I know of familiar
with my committee with this the
political stage has to be set for
the project and many engineers in
projects are not aware of the political
maneuvering that has gone on before the
project comes into being in this case
the councilman in the city of New York
in 1878 were very much under the
influence of the gas lighting people and
so the gas lighting people put a lot of
pressure on the councilmen in the city
of New York when the gas lighting people
learned that there was to be an effort
to create an electric lighting system
and the gas people said that the
councilmen don't let these people open
up the streets
because the trend the distribution lines
would be put underground in New York
City so one way to block the project was
not to give the Edison Electric Light
Company permission to open the streets
well Grosvenor Lowry went to work
lobbying and in other ways in bringing
about a change in attitude on the part
of the councilmen of New York City and I
think you can well imagine what he might
have done to change their minds so the
political stage was set and well quickly
I don't want to dwell on this but but
it's an anecdote one thing Larry did he
invited all the councilmen out to see a
test of the Edison Electric light system
in 1879 and he was taking the counter
but he brought him out in a handsome
railway car took them around and showed
them a proto electric light system that
Edison had put up at his Menlo Park
laboratories and these people were
becoming very bored the councilmen with
what they were seeing and then the
councilmen were moved into Edison's
laboratory it was completely dark
suddenly the lights came on the first
display of indoor lighting for these
people and when the lights came on what
was displayed a marvelous meal from
Delmonico's
with much liquid refreshment to go along
with it and incidentally that that
banquet had to end within an hour
in 35 minutes because Edison's electric
lights have would not burn for long an
Allen 35 minutes now this is this is
program management we have to respect it
it sets the stage now we go into Edison
as a Edison as the project manager now
let's forget the heroic Edison of the of
the books we read when we were young
this man was not working alone in a
garret he had one of the best equipped
laboratories in the United States he
also had his team his team included a
physicist who had studied in Berlin it
included marvelously talented
machine-tool people they were also
chemists in his team as well as glass
blowers who were brought into it for
this project I could go on and name the
craftsmen but the point to be made here
that the historian wants to make Edison
had brought this group of this team
together and I know many of you have
been involved in teams Edison had
brought this team together in earlier
years to work on the telephone and to
work on the phonograph man he had this
team in place so he had to choose a
product a product he had to choose a
system that could utilize the resources
in the personnel and he had in his
disposal so I think we need to remind
ourselves that we are constrained by the
organizational concepts that come out of
the past and in which we are working now
we are constrained that there are only
certain projects we do the only certain
projects that are suitable so Edison
very what I decided that electric
lighting was suitable for the team that
he had in place now he once he had his
team in place and he had his encrypt in
place then there was the problem of
conceptualizing the electric light
system and I think this is where
Edison's brilliance along with the
intelligence of some of his team comes
into play
and if I may have the other the diagram
yes there we are there's nothing in
Edison's notebooks that gives me the
evidence to feel confident in saying
that what I'm telling you now is other
than a hypothesis but from
circumstantial evidence this is the way
that I believe Edison reasoned his way
to his concept his design concept as you
know when a project a design concept
comes before preliminary design well
from this little exercise in following
Edison's reasoning I think you may
better understand the main so-called and
I would say yes his genius you'll note
the interdisciplinary character of the
thought processes he realized he had to
analyze the market and with whom was he
competing he was competing with gas
lighting and from gas lighting he drew
an analogy with regard to the overall
architecture of the system that he would
design he had to be concerned about the
economics of competing but also this
analogy with the architects it was very
helpful to him gas lighting all the gas
companies were then distributing from
central plants that were distributing
through an entire city from one central
plant and Edison decided that his
architecture would be like that
architecture but let's go back to the
economics of the system he looked he had
a general concept of what the system
would be like he would have distribution
lines of copper it would have generators
of course and it would have the electric
lights and he reasoned with the help of
some of probably with Upton the man
who'd studied in Berlin on the Helmholtz
he reasoned that
reverse aiding in the system the
bottleneck if you prefer the reversal in
the system was the cost of Coppa so
here's a man who's into designing an
electrical system but he realized that
materials are his problem and it isn't
didn't hesitate to move from one area
from materials there into the electrical
area into the chemical area wherever the
problem was he would move he wasn't
bound by any disciplinary restraints so
he said the problem is the cost of
copper the cost of copper in the
distribution lands then he turns from
materials and cost to the science that
he had in his disposal now remember this
is 1878 in the science available to
electricians is very limited he had
Jules law and it had Ohm's law and from
thinking with Jules law and thinking
with Ohm's law he knew that the losses
in distribution would be in equal to the
square of the current times the
resistance all to put it another way the
energy loss in the conductors would be
proportional to the current squared
times the length of the conductor
divided by the cross-sectional area
if one increased the cross-sectional
area of the distribution lands then one
would reduce the energy loss in the
distribution lines but increase the
cross-sectional area was to increase the
use of copper therefore this was not an
option for him to continue to increase
the cross section area cross sectional
area until he lowered his energy lost in
distribution so assuming a fixed length
and keeping the cross section area low
how was he to solve the problem of
getting the required amount of energy
into his electric lights now he knew
from Ohm's law that the electric lights
had to have a power or an anti on energy
consumption which was equal to the
current
the voltage now he knew from the energy
loss and the distribution lines he had
to keep his current alone because the
energy loss was carrying square I'm
cooling across into this in such detail
it may seem elementary but this is the
way I think the man's mind was working
and so he's therefore he has to keep the
current low because Karen square he'll
raise the voltage so he have will have
sufficient current times voltage to give
him the energy he needs at his electric
lamps now how does he raised the voltage
and lower the current I went into Knoll
Encyclopedia Brittanica for that period
and a fan of the way that resistance
Ohm's law was stated in those days was
that the resistance equals the ratio of
voltage to current and as the obvious
answer I think that's the Eureka moment
for Edison was when he saw that by
raising the resistance of the electric
light filament he could increase the
voltage that would be going through his
transmission distribution lines and
reduced the current so that is why as a
man and we go into popular stories now
spend months trying to find a light
filament that gave a maximum of
resistance and what he ended up with and
that determines even today the standards
of our electric lighting system he found
that he could he could get a filament
that would take a current of 1 amp that
it would have a resistance of a hundred
ohms and so that would give him a
hundred watts and so there you have the
standards that we have in our electric
lights today because the highest
resistance he could get was a hundred
ohms you know he needed an amp 1 amp to
get the wattage he need why that wattage
of 100 watts because a hundred watts
gave him the same lighting intensity as
a gas light
was giving at that particular time so
Edison's conceptual design I hope that
you are is impressed by the man's
thinking process as much as I am even
though the scientific laws and not
esoteric the quantitative activity is
not remarkable but putting together the
various aspects of the problem is what I
find extremely impressive now let's go
on to the open system he now has the
essence of his electric technical system
his closed system now we're going to the
organization of the Edison companies I
have interviewed a number of persons in
the field of complex systems and and
they have told me that it's necessary if
the closed system is radical if the
technology is radical it is advantageous
to create a new organization to nurture
the radical technology they tell me and
I'm thinking about an interview with
Simon Remo and who worked on the Atlas
missile did systems engineering for the
Atlas missile and I'm also thinking
about general Schreiber who presided
over the Atlas missile and I'm thinking
about people who presided over the
Polaris missile and in both those cases
the Polaris and the Atlas and numerous
other system designs the system builders
not only come not only produce the new
technology but produce new organizations
in order to get the radical technology
outside of the bureaucratic structure
general Schreiber told me and I'll talk
about Atlas next time general Schreiber
said I had to get out those away from
those bastards at the Pentagon
he said I was dealing with people who
could say no and could not say yes the
assistant secretaries I had to get
outside the system so he forms a new
organization the Western Development
Corporation part of the Air Force but
outside of the Air Force and the
Pentagon bureaucratic structure will
look what Edison did Edison and his
visors did not depend upon existing
manufacturing companies but they form
this consortium of companies in which
they the parent Edison Company the
Edison Electric Light Company the
venture capital patent holding company
had interests through stock in most
cases so you have the illuminating
company which is a utility the Edison
Electric illuminating company in New
York Brooklyn in other illuminating
companies the Thomas Edison construction
company to construct the electric light
and power systems the Edison machine
works that manufactured dynamos the
Edison tube company underground
distribution lamp works obvious Bergman
was fixtures and other manufacturing
came from United Edison what is worth
noting here this system bill the Edison
and his team they have control of the
manufacturer like the German General
Electric I told you a moment againt that
controlling the manufacturer and they
controlling the market for the
manufacturer that is controlling the
utilities that buys the generators that
are made by the Edison machine works you
know what's new mr. gates in this effort
to get control not only of the
production but the content and
distribution and so forth and so we see
this control at a very very early day
incidentally most of the other day
manufacturing companies here were
combined in the early 1890s into the
General Electric Company now I want to
turn to a a more recent well I should
say that the system was deployed in New
York in Brooklyn and elsewhere
and the the company the Consolidated
Edison company flourishes in New York it
was established by Edison
yeah those many years ago etc etc etc I
don't think we need to go into the
further development and deployment let's
now turn to the opponet which I think
you all know is the beginning or the
predecessor of the Internet and this
story is I think one of the remarkable
accounts of system building in the last
30 years so I would spend some time
telling the story about the net again I
say I'm I'm mean to say telling a story
because I know most of you are involved
in very elegant problem-solving your
reports a rigorous and quantitative and
I'm telling a story which you usually do
not do in your professional work but the
reason I'm telling a story is because
stories can well they're many reasons I
couldn't do the kind of work you're
doing but another reason is stories
encompass messy complexity in a more
embracing inclusive way than a more
scientific elegant account can do so a
story is one way of conveying messy yes
and I'm arguing and I'm arguing with
some of my friends at MIT that MIT
students need to hear more stories a
messy complexity they may find it soft
and they may find it at first not
congenial but the people I've talked to
out in the field often say to me yes yes
do tell messy stories because the mess
is what many of the young engineers will
soon be involved with are a turning to
the ARPANET in following the pattern
that I have described in the case of the
classic Edison
story let's begin with program
management of the ARPANET now the
program manager of the ARPANET this is
my terminology some people in the
audience may disagree the program
management was and was the
responsibility of DARPA the Defense
Advanced Research Projects Agency and I
trust most of you familiar with it it
has been a remarkably successful funder
and nourish of projects since 1958 it is
still flourishing it has changed in
character and policy but it larisa's it
has been called at times Advanced
Research Projects Agency APPA at other
times the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency I refer to it as open it
was founded established in 1958 in
response to the Sputnik if you don't
remember I do remember you may have
heard that after the Russians launched
Sputnik that was great anxiety in this
country that our technology was falling
behind and there were some measures had
to be taken the Eisenhower
administration felt in order to respond
to this problem and one of the responses
was DARPA which was to nourish and
develop in fun radical technology I'm
using radical in a very general way but
how the innovative technology prefer now
note that DARPA is a pentagon Agency
DARPA gives military funding but I
stress that because DARPA has funded a
number of projects that in their impact
and even in the process of being created
seem rather distant from military needs
but let me go on with the project
management that Appa was engaged in
when the organization decided to do a
computer network all right now first
what's momentarily distracted me I see a
quote I want to give you here
one of the major DARPA personalities
Licklider said what the military needs
is what the business maine needs is what
the scientist needs so what the military
funds can be useful of advantage to
businessmen and scientists as in this
statement can be made as long as a level
of abstraction is high where the
businessman and the scientists and the
military fund their needs differ is when
one lowers of the project down the
ladder of abstraction two very practical
specific applications but when working
at a general level a computer network
general and all of these contingencies
these clients can be responding to at
this level another person I interviewed
tell me that the military is a very big
Society the United States is a very big
Society this is an awful person
so is it any surprise when we fund a
military society need we also funding a
civil society needs both for example
need communications both need
calculations etc etc all right the
another characteristic of this program
manager APPA besides its willingness to
innovate on a rather abstract level and
solve
respond to a number of interest was that
the people in the early days who came in
to opportu managed as program managers
they were often on leave for two or
three years from industry on leave from
universities for two or three years so
what were they bringing they were
bringing with them a university style or
an industry research style what else two
or three years and then they
left the the project was complete for
them their performance was over they
left and others came in it is difficult
to argue that offer was a bureaucracy
with hardening of the arteries when you
have these people coming in for short
periods with new ideas soon to be
replaced by other people with new ideas
another characteristic of opera the
program management this staff was
extremely lean relatively few people
compared to other agencies the year and
another characteristic was that Appa
preferred to fund very large expensive
projects and this meant that small staff
could manage instead of having to manage
a thousand little projects you had a
small staff five or six people in case
of one of the branches of ARPA that is
if though which I'll talk about in a
minute you have five or six people
managing millions of dollars but only a
few projects now I want to say something
better the remarkable project manager
I'm sorry I've been talking about
program management now I want to talk
about a project manager a person who
worked with in the context of Appa and
that is Joseph called Rob net Licklider
who was usually called lick lick later
he set a pattern of project management
that I think has had enormous influence
in the world of project management and
engineering to this very day he had a
number of devoted followers who admired
his style saw him as a visionary and put
into place and into and put into and
deployed the kind of project management
style for which he became noted let me
say something about Lickliter and the
time I have notes a man's pedigree this
gives us insight into a very interesting
period of
it's history and some fascinating people
Lickliter was a psychologist by training
I should say here that he was the first
head of the information processing
techniques office egipto which was that
part of DARPA Appa which presided over
the creation of the ARPANET egipto a
Licklider from 1962 to 64 was the head
of it toe information processing
techniques office of DARPA okay but what
I want to stress this main with a
background in psychology had a
remarkably rich career that gave him
through experience from unusual
capabilities and maybe some of you had
similar experiences he doing World War
two and many of the people who came to
the fore in the period of it which I'm
speaking in the 60s and the 50s had
interesting World War two experiences in
the realm of Science and Technology a
World War two for scientists and
engineers was a remarkable learning
experience well lick later during World
War two had been a part of a cyclo
acoustics laboratory at Harvard
University then after the war he moves
to MIT the hidden acoustics laboratory
it's in had as a main moved from
acoustics to computers so we'll see now
while at MIT he became involved in those
organizations that were providing rich
experiences for those who would take the
risk of becoming a part of these new and
risk-taking organizations for example he
became a research associate in the MIT
research laboratory of electronics now
if that laboratory was famous in the
1950s and 60s for an interdisciplinary
approach interdisciplinary with
something still failing you in the
engineering world
so he he becomes a part of the MIT
research laboratory of electronics he
also takes part in project Charles a
project Charles was a summer study
project we don't have these projects
anymore the summer studies were very
popular at MIT in the 50s and 60s what
was a summer project a summer project
was funded by the military generously
funded the project involved inviting a
number of academics and industrial
people and military people maybe 30
maybe 40 that neighborhood him number to
take off from their responsibilities
from for an entire summer later it
became sometimes six months and focused
at a bucolic site geographical site some
way up in the mountains down at the
seashore these forty or sixty people
freed from their responsibilities would
concentrate upon one particular problem
of interest to the military for six
months or a summer and one of the major
projects was called project Charles
which dedicated the people who were
members of Project Charles dedicated
themselves to setting up the the after
the air defense system called sage
well Lickliter took part in one of these
summer projects and i'm told from by
people whom i interviewed at the summer
projects that when you entered the door
wherever the meeting was being held that
you were told to forget your discipline
to forget that you were an expert
and that just focus on the problem and
go wherever the problem took you into
whatever feel of engineering or whatever
field of science because they're no
experts in this area we're exploring and
incidentally that was the same
techniques used at iran cooperation
about the same time forget your
expertise let the problem decide where
you will do your thinking so Licklider
was
part of Project Charles also he heard
about Norbert Wiener I think all of you
have heard about Norbert Wiener and so
he became a part of the group that would
mix and meet with Norbert Wiener so this
man had a rich rich MIT experience and
after MIT and in the electrical
engineering department the acoustics lab
he went to Lincoln Laboratory that was
another great learning experience in the
50s Lincoln Laboratory was established
to do the research and development for
the sage a defense project but if it's
but funded by the Air Force it had some
of the most advanced computer computers
in the world and so when had an
opportunity to go to Lincoln
laboratories you know what you still
admitted my minister by MIT and then one
had hands-on with the most advanced
technological and especially computer
equipment then from there he went to
bolt Beranek and Newman a high
technology firm founded in 1948 I think
you're familiar with his firm today it's
a major player in the acoustics and the
computing field so he moves on to bow
pour Anakin human rich experiences which
prepared him for his work at epitome nei
Licklider was visionary and what was his
vision he had a vision in 1919 in the
mid-1950s he had a vision of time
sharing on a computer and he also had
the vision of interconnecting computers
and he often gathered together people in
the Cambridge area maybe over a few
drinks to talk about the future the
possibilities of time sharing the
possibilities of computer in a
connection he spoke a main computer
symbiosis now Lickliter in this early
period the 1950s was not moving towards
a development of the CIM
peuta as a calculating arithmetic device
he was one of the pioneers who saw that
a computer could be used for control and
decision-making and other purposes
so the Maine has vision he has a number
of followers and there I would like to
show you the click light and network hmm
I hope you have it before you on one of
the charts to me this is a remarkable
Network please note the movements of
these people these are people with most
of them intimately associated they in
the majority of them have similar
experiences to which he which he had MIT
Electrical Engineering Lincoln lab some
of them in bolt Beranek and Newman this
was the context in which computer
pioneers who made the opponet learned
the trade and no two movements of
relatively few people and the
organizations with which they were
associated now turning to the choice of
problem choice to work on the ARPANET
brought a simple origin Appa was funding
a number of computer research centers in
the United States in major universities
such as Carnegie Mellon MIT UCLA
Stanford Research Laboratory and so
forth opera was funding these computer
research centers actually these were
computer research centers which
Licklider had his network
located and he funded his network
through these computer centers now the
cost of the computers was very high and
it was thought that if one could bring
these centers to share their computers
through inter connecting their computers
ARPA cost would be reduced and according
to robert taylor who was one of the
egipto heads the idea for this inter
cost-saving in the connection came to
him when he was sitting his in his
office in washington remember he's a nip
toe head and he had he had terminals
from three time sharing computers in his
office I think one of the time sharing
computers was at MIT another may have
been somewhere in the Washington area
I'm not sure but he had three terminals
from three times sharing computers and
they were not interconnected and he said
well the obvious thing is to
interconnect now the time sharing
computers and the need of course is to
reduce cost by time by sharing computer
capacity and sharing software now a word
about this is the inauguration of the
project the conceptual design of the
project was worked out a distributed
committee in the case of Edison in the
case of Edison we had the people who
came up with the conceptual design that
thought process that reasoning I went
through they were located in one place
they went a hierarchical structure
headed by Edison but it's remarkable
that the conceptual design for the
ARPANET came about through informal
meetings of the heads of these various
computer centers informal meetings
called by Licklider and blick later in
his and one of the interviews that I've
used said oh the heads of the research
centers
would gather at some place for a
committee meeting a committee of
research heads and we'd have some
alcohol in the late evening and then I
might bring up the subject of computer
networking and we'd stay up into the
late hours and in perhaps an idea for
the Imps the information processor would
somebody would come up Wesley Roberts
would come up with that and then
somebody might mention packet switching
and we would talk about that
so what Lickliter was doing is through
with his network he was drawing out of
them the ideas through discussion that
would become the conceptual design of
the opponet now the next step in the
procedure was that up to-- the office
that would preside over this development
egipto centered a a call a request for
bids to a number of companies and the
request for bids have this basic
conceptual design in the request we want
a computer network with so many nodes we
want to use packet switching we also are
interested in having interface computers
that will allow the host computers
although they are different designed to
interconnect even though they have
different characteristics they will
interconnect due to the telephone
network thursday's imps these interface
computers these ideas were coming up
through these discussions that took
place over a number of months now the
fundamental contract the basic contract
for the design of the imps was given to
bolt Beranek and Newman the company
which you remember Licklider was a
researcher at and then later a vice
president of so this company had the
responsibility for developing the
interface computer
imp I want to just say a word as a move
to conclusion about the style of
research at BBN because I think this
style of research at BBN has become
rather commonplace style in the world of
projects today you can tell me whether
this is true or not but let me read a
quote about from Robert Kahn who was at
BBN he said BBN this is from an
interview BBN was a kind of hybrid
version of Harvard and MIT in the sense
that most of the people there were the
faculty or former faculty at either
Harvard or MIT the role of MIT plays in
this episode is a remarkably active one
if you've ever spent any time at either
of those places you would know
what a unique kind of organization BBN
was a lot of the students of those
places spend time at BBN it was kind of
like a super hyped up version of the
union of the two Harvard and MIT except
that you didn't have to worry about
classes and teaching you could just
focus on research if we sort of the Khan
yacked of the research business very
distilled the cultured BBN at the time
was to do interesting things and to move
on to the next interesting things and
there was more insane to come up with
interesting ideas and explore them than
to try to capitalize on them once
they've been developed so bbm BBN will
develop the hard way in some of the
software for the ARPANET and also one
more quote about the style of BBN one of
the team managers hearts and what we
were doing in developing this hardware
was a labor of love it was all fun and I
have enough collaborating evidence to
accept this he's and we all in on the
team a team about 10 or 15 of BBN we
thought holistically we reached our
decisions by consensus the team leader
would only come in when you couldn't
reach a consensus there was no
micromanagement here we were a suitably
black boxed
he's now another interview with one of
the persons at BBN said when a
breakthrough occurred we we'd run in and
say look I got this running somebody
come and type this on the teletype this
is exciting
something is cycling now another
characteristic of the this research it
was going on on DARPA was the
meritocracy it wasn't a hierarchical
activity and one more quote a group of
graduate students where were set up as a
committee at another site in BBN but
this type of thing went on a BBN - a
group of graduate students was set up to
develop the protocols for the internet
and here's a quote from another graduate
students we would just rank amateurs and
we were expecting that some Authority
would finally come along and say here's
how we're going to do it a professor
would come along and say here's how we
were going to do it and nobody ever came
along so we were sort of tentatively
feeling away into how we could go about
getting this software up and running and
there many many many examples of this
sort of flat organization name in
conclusion I want to show you I don't
show they up in that dog wellyes quickly
the opponet diagrams these are historic
this is the first diagram I encountered
it was done in longhand and it showed
one end that's the interface computer
that connects the host with the
telephone network and one host computer
let's see the next one this is a and by
August 1972 the other was in a few years
earlier three years earlier and this is
a network as it was in 1972 I like to
show this because the computer network
looks very much like the growth of the
computer network like the growth of a
railroad network next one please
and in conclusion something I hope we
can talk about it at another time I
wasn't able to give you all of the
information I'd like to giving you about
the style and be behind the oppos'd
aisle of management I hope I indicated
and suggested it to you this
but out of the study I've done I've come
up with a contrast between the kind of
production management that took place
say it Ford Motor Company in the 1920s
and the kind of project management that
I account count on these projects today
and this run very quickly through the
contrast before World War two
hierarchical now today flat used
specialization was well-regarded Nantz
interdisciplinary integration of a
coordination rational order was the
objective now amidst the complexity is
accepted heterogeneity is accepted we
could go on down the list experts were
highly regarded now it's more of a
meritocracy as the anecdote I gave you
about the graduate students tightly
coupled over network let's have the next
one very quickly and then and then
program control against feedback control
systems engineering denser Taylorism and
it seems to me as we move into the world
where projects play an increasing role
these are some of the characteristics of
project management thank you a few
minutes for questions or commentary
either from people here at MIT or people
at a distance anyone like to add or ask
any questions or comment professor I'd
like to know if there's plans to post
the slides that were shown some were a
bit difficult to read from a distance
yes yes we do do plan to post the slides
so they will be available for everyone
yes secondly I have a question about the
Thomas Edison slide showing the
organization that was early in the in
the presentation you showed that as
being separate companies or was
that the forerunner to Ford's concept
that was very highly vertically
integrated it wasn't clear to me
speaking of the Edison companies I think
he was speaking of the Edison companies
the ones that would established like the
Edison manufacturing company and the
utilities and so forth these these
companies were it wasn't wasn't a
vertical no it wasn't vertical it was
horizontal the companies interacted but
there wasn't a central management at the
at in 1882 when these companies were
established to manufacture the
generators and the companies established
to manufacture the light bulbs and the
underground distribution and so forth
nor was a horizontal it was a horizontal
arrangement with the the parent company
the Edison Electric Light Company the
patent holding company the investment
company having stock interest in these
companies and some control through stock
interests but it was a loosely coupled
system organizational system bang
one of the terms that I was looking for
in this comparison that didn't see its
emergent its project the project
management that you described in ARPA
seemed to me a much more at least in
this project a much more emergent kind
of thing because as we all know the the
ARPANET wasn't intended to be a
communication network originally and of
course that emerged and and so on the
graduate students who sort of developed
their own standards and so on
could we add emergent to this project
management emerging over time out of the
interaction of the various socio
technical elements but not managed not
planned in advance yeah it certainly was
that join certainly was a emergence to
project because at the beginning as I
said the objective was to lower cost the
primary objective I haven't talked about
the military background
the primary immediate objective was to
lower cost through the sharing of
computer resources and software
resources but as you point out open and
within a few years after that
demonstration of the in and of the
ARPANET in 1972 within a few years
email became the major traffic generator
on the oppenent and there was no
intention at the beginning of using it
primarily as a mode of communication and
then also I think as you know I didn't
go into this because I assumed you knew
it
the opponet after a while was turned
over the military I took over the
military aspects of the ARPANET and the
other parts of it were turned over to
civilian agencies NSF for example became
a major funder of computer networks and
so the opponet was the one at the core
but then a number of other networks
funded by other agencies were joined
through protocol develop
to the arpanet so that wasn't expected
either know that it's good to stress
this and the Edison didn't foresee many
of the future developments in electric
lighting power he didn't see alternating
current he did not see regional electric
light and power systems glad you made
the point doing life tom I'm trying to
get a better grasp on the difference
between an open and a closed system
would you characterize the ARPANET
project is an open system or a closed
one originally as it was as it started
out yes don't be sure this is on the
opponet I call an open system because it
tow established a number of these
research centers and the research
centers were the organizational
framework within which the technical
network was housed so often the opponet
involved not only the technical aspects
the computers the telephone system etc
but it also involved the organization's
the research centers at the various
universities and you couldn't have one
without the other
so people that ape tow had to nurture
the organizations at the same time they
when they're training the technical
content and it was also an open system
because the designers of a system had to
clear the funding through Congress also
the airforce the military generally was
funding and funding had to be arranged
etcetera so it was it was a complex
system that involved technical
components funding components political
problems organizational
and that's the point I'm trying to
stress as most of the technical systems
to deal with all embedded in a larger
structure that can be called an open
system and as Joann points if these open
systems often emerging systems and have
many of these complicated
characteristics extremely difficult to
manage once they're in place great
thanks doc and you because of this
audience I'll ask you did do you find
that projects are increasingly common in
the organizations within which you work
I gave you the analogy of the theater
where a group is brought together for a
specific length of time to solve one
particular problem and the people on the
group may come from various parts of the
organizational company then after the
project is fulfilled the goals are met
then the project dis pains that people
go back to their respective areas of
commitment or wherever they are home
bases
I have a question but I my thoughts are
spinning such I hope I can clarify it in
a way I'm I'm affiliated with the air
force right now and my questions kind of
go back to the idea of the conceptual
design and how you talked about the
network that was among these people and
the the loose kind of style that was
there in in the research I've been doing
I've been seeing the Air Force has tried
to capture these networks of people but
they're not being very successful
instead what's happening is those
projects that are getting funded are
from a different kind of a person that
has an another network and informal
network I guess what I'm trying to say
the Air Force has tried to formalize and
structure and establish networks to
emulate some of these attributes that
you've talked about but they're failing
and and it's this this informal network
is the one that's still working and and
I I'd be interested in your comments on
that and maybe because it's something
the Air Force is struggling with because
it allows me to go back to go back to
Licklider
I think the showed this diagram which
you have of the liquid and network and
Lickliter cultivated this network
informally but he also structured it
formally in that he he would help the
people in his network become located in
these research centers and then he would
also when he had this funding resource
set egipto which is part of Appa he
would fund people in his network who
were located in these various research
centers but again only informal level
level again as I said his
people often gather together and
meetings he would call and talking to
late hours about concept for time
sharing or concept for computer
networking but so he was playing the
informal and the phone Alma being again
placing the people in an organizational
structure these research centers for
example so I think a person the the
answer I think the most direct answer to
very interesting question is in
government today project manages and
that's what Lickliter was he was a
project manager for are extremely
important and their project managers in
the Air Force as you know but I've been
told by some of the people whom I've
interviewed that the project managers
today on not giving that given the
freedom and the leeway to organize
informal networks to draw out conceptual
designs as freely and imaginatively as
they once were able to do so I think the
answer to your question is is put your
attention upon the functioning of the
project managers people like lik light
on the APIs and what kind of success are
they having what kind of reinforcement
are they getting what's a freedom of
action do they have and again I repeat
ER I've been told that the project
managers do not have the sort of freedom
to to maneuver and to develop and
fulfill imagine them concepts that they
once had because of a number of
bureaucratic constraints and regulations
and I think I know what you mean by an
informal network that is a special
interest group that is responding to the
needs own to say its particular small
group and you don't have this drawing
upon a community that Lickliter drew
upon yes
let me on behalf of all of us thank
professor use for this fascinating
account of two remarkably different
projects I think as you've explained
them whether one is the old-fashioned
way of doing things the edison way in
the art was the new fashion what I think
is one for all of us to think about but
the contrast is rather stark I would say
in terms of the differences in the
organizational style and the approach
for these two two projects both
eminently successful in terms of their
projects I would recommend again to
everyone to book particularly those of
you who are interested in MIT because
there's a lot of MIT in this book I'm
really impressed as you look through it
the impact I think that MIT has had when
all of us should feel good about this in
terms of the way of thinking about
complex systems if this has been an
organization that it's been deeply
immersed in this for many many years as
I said at the outset of this the
presentation today professor uses on
campus for the semester as a guest of
MIT he will be around in the MIT
community I think gee delighted to to
meet with anyone who might like to talk
to him further about these he'll be
giving another public lecture on October
30th to pursue some of the topics that
he talked about today and I think talk
about some other of these large-scale
projects and he'll be meeting with the
SDM students in private so please join
me again in thanking professor use for
this very illuminating presentation